Despite the fact that it covers the majority
of our planet’s surface, we know remarkably
little about the oceans.
Well, we know how to navigate them and how
to send boats from one continent to another
- the surface of the water is usually a calm,
safe place where all you expect to encounter
are other humans and the occasional storm.
What’s below the surface is another story.
Scientists estimate that we’ve only explored
maybe 5 percent of the world’s oceans and
what lies in them.
On top of that, they estimate that we’ve
only encountered and cataloged 10 percent
of marine life.
That means that 95 percent of the ocean is
unexplored and untouched by humans, and that
90 percent of the ocean species have never
even been seen by humans.
It makes you think - just what kind of stuff
is down there?
It could be anything.
Even mundane ocean life can be deeply strange
and bizarre.
There are sharks that live for over three
hundred years, blind fish that hunt by only
smell, jellyfish that are ‘reborn’ whenever
they die.
If normal ocean life is this terrifying and
explanation-defying, what kinds of anomalies
could the oceans we swim and fish in be playing
host to?
One such anomaly is SCP-835.
But before we get started, SCP-835 is an old,
old file.
It’s one of the earliest in the Foundation’s
database, in fact.
Like many of the Foundation’s earliest documents,
it’s been heavily redacted and expunged,
to the point where large blocks of the text
are missing.
Not to mention the fact that it’s been locked
behind a content filter.
But SCP-835 is unique not because it’s been
expunged and redacted, but because it’s
had them lifted.
Versions of the file and its addendum that
are cleared of the redactions have been declassified
and released by order of O5-11 to all viewers.
For some reason, whatever was so secret about
this file no longer applies.
But before we take a look at the declassified
documentation, let’s look at the old version
to get an idea of what exactly we’re dealing
with here.
The attached image for SCP-835 is, to put
it simply, gross.
It’s what appears to be some kind of bone
or muscular growth underwater, a bit like
coral but much more organic and flesh-like
in shape.
The growth is mostly white and brown, but
large sections are grown over with what looks
like some kind of black mold spores.
It’s large, too, almost the size of a person’s
chest, and seems to continue out of frame.
The caption is simply: “Still image from
Recording 81”.
It’s not even clear if this growth, whatever
it is, is SCP-835 or not.
Continuing on to the file - the object class
is Keter, and the Special Containment Procedures
are lengthier than most articles’, and very
detailed.
They explain that SCP-835 must constantly
be monitored and checked to see if it’s
growing or expanding.
In the event that it becomes hostile to Foundation
personnel, something known only as “Suppression
Tactic A-A6” is to be activated until it
ceases any hostile action.
The anomaly has to be contained in the open
ocean rather than moved to a water tank or
such, because of “the highly aggressive
response of SCP-835 to confinement for any
length of time”.
So whatever it is, it’s alive.
It’s expanding and growing, and seems capable
of knowing when it’s being placed into containment
- and responding angrily.
It’s not only sentient, it’s intelligent
and aware.
They go on to say that SCP-835’s waste has
to be immediately collected and contained,
and that it is to be fed two times every day,
though what exactly is going to be fed to
it is redacted in this version of the file.
It can also be moved to a new location up
to two times a year, but only if the current
location can’t support it anymore, and if
the move has been approved by the site directors.
On top of that, personnel have to stay away
from SCP-835 - at least fifteen feet.
They also need to have safety harnesses attached
to winches on the boat.
If anyone so much as touches SCP-835, all
of the winches will activate and rapidly yank
all the divers back to the boat.
From there, “Suppression Tactic A-A6”
is again instituted.
But there’s another line: if a staff member
touches SCP-835 and is ‘captured’ by it,
then the anomaly is to be monitored around
the clock until the subject has been released.
Very ominous containment procedures.
This predator, if it is a predator, has a
penchant for consuming people and needs to
be avoided at all costs.
But if someone is caught, it… releases them
after a while?
The description of the document clears some
things up: SCP-835 is a mass of polyps, or
tissue growths, that resemble coral.
It’s huge and heavy, though its full weight
is again redacted, and the individual polyps
are also huge, over a meter long (much longer
than any known coral species).
The central mass is oval and has a huge 3
meter long polyp on each side of it, but can’t
move or budge because of its huge weight.
Instead, it uses huge tentacles extending
from the polyps to dig into the ground and
anchor it in place against the ocean currents.
These are the same tentacles that are used
for ‘feeding’ and are covered in a sticky
glue-like adhesive.
They’re not just long and strong, either
- tests have recorded them damaging stainless
steel plating.
And speaking of plating, SCP-835 is covered
in it.
Not steel, but some kind of organic coral
that’s much harder than steel and couldn’t
be broken by even diamond-drill bits.
All the Foundation could get were small samples.
And if that wasn’t bad enough, the Foundation’s
positive that SCP-835 is growing, like the
containment procedures suggested, and it's
growing fast, up to fifty pounds in a single
day if it's left uninterrupted.
But it can be stopped - it reacts to certain
chemicals that make it “close up” like
an oyster and stop growing for twenty-four
hours at a time.
Based on that, the Foundation’s been able
to develop and use a chemical cocktail to
force it to halt - the aforementioned Suppression
Tactic A-A6.
However, the results of testing it have been
redacted.
In case the anomaly wasn’t disgusting enough,
it also vomits.
That’s right - every couple of hours, it
expels a large mass of some liquidy sludge
material from both side - so to speak.
After sample testing, the scientists realized
it really is vomit - well, part of it.
The substance is mostly semi-digested food,
fecal material, and semen, but also contains
live samples of biohazardous viruses, bacteria,
and parasites.
Some that the Foundation hadn’t even encountered
before SCP-835!
One of these bacteria, 835-I5 is a big problem
for containing SCP-835, but exactly why that
is, is unfortunately, expunged from the file
as well.
Between this lethal witches brew of dangerous
diseases and the diamond-hard shell that covers
SCP-835’s internal guts, it is nearly impossible
to neutralize or even damage it.
Even if you do crack the shell - the diseased
fluid inside would leak out and infect you
full of diseases in seconds.
Wow, that is….kind of crazy.
Yeah so SCP-835 is a really, really nasty
customer.
I mean just by looks alone, it’s easy to
tell 835 is probably nothing to mess with.
But a simple visual of the thing in your line
of sight does no justice in showing how actually
dangerous and disgusting it really is.
If you try to break it, you get your immune
system overrun by a cocktail of diseases - if
it doesn’t manage to eat you first.
The document has one addendum: an after-action
report by a member of Mobile Task Force Zeta-Nine:
the notorious “Mole Rats”.
The Mole Rats are one of the Foundation’s
most elite teams of special operations troops.
Like all MTFs, they have a very specific specialization,
one thing they do better than anyone else
in the world.
For Zeta-nine, it’s cramped spaces.
The Task Force is highly-trained in exploring
dangerous constricted areas, especially those
that lie underground.
From subterranean caves to endless staircases
and basement labyrinths, the Mole Rats are
the best of the best at getting in and getting
out.
The Mobile Task Force Zeta-nine had been performing
an investigation on SCP-835, albeit when it
was considerably smaller: only a meager four
tons, and hadn’t formed a second big polyp
yet.
Just like usual, four members of the Mole
Rats were chosen to begin the investigation,
equipped with underwater isolation suits to
ward off any biological threats.
Lieutenant C , Sergeants L and M, and Corporal
H, a rookie team member who was training with
them and was ordered to only observe.
They took a small underwater drone with them
- one that would come in very handy.
At first, SCP-835 didn’t act hostile or
aggressive towards the members of the team.
In fact, it even allowed members to swim up
to it and touch it without reacting.
They couldn’t even tell if it was alive
or not, so they sent the drone to approach
the huge polyp on the north side while they
went around to the small entrance on the other
side of the rock.
Corporal H was told to remain there and make
sure that the power cable to the drone didn’t
break off or snap.
Everything seemed calm.
Suddenly the drone’s claw arm jerked back,
having gotten stuck in something, and began
thrashing around.
Not wanting to wake the creature, Corporal
H moved forward and tried to free the claw
- but then he became trapped too.
The other members of the team heard him on
the radio, screaming for them to come and
help him, and that he’d been grabbed by
some “horrible tentacle thing” that was
dragging him towards the polyp, that had opened
up into a mouth.
The incident left Lieutenant C a bit ruffled
afterward:
“Jesus Christ.
I can’t do this, he was just a kid!
It was his first mission, I should’ve kept
my eye on him!”.
After a moment, she composes herself, and
begins to explain what happened:
“The anomaly grabbed Corporal H, having
fooled the rest of us.
What we thought was the entrance was just
some cave, while the polyp on the north side
was the real “entrance” into SCP-835.
The tentacles came out of it’s smaller polyps,
grabbed Corporal H and began dragging him
in while he thrashed around and screamed.
The boat tried to pull in the winch, but from
all the activity, the line snapped in two.
Corporal H was pulled inside SCP-835 and eaten”.
The Lieutenant explains that she swam over
and hooked herself to his outreached hand
when the boat began winching her up.
She said just as she assured him that they’re
going to be fine and that she’s not letting
go, her line snapped and they were both suddenly
pulled inside.
She breaks for a moment, before describing
the inside as like a wet, pulsing tube, like
how intestines look on colonoscopies.
They were both steadily being pulled in by
the muscle contractions - what doctors call
peristalsis, the way your body moves food
down your throat and through your intestines.
The only reason they weren’t dissolved or
crushed was because of the isolation suits
they were wearing, but they still couldn’t
move.
Corporal H had vomited in his suit, but they
were both alive.
The Lieutenant, thinking fast, figured out
that if they were moving through its body,
they would come out the other end in seventy
two hours.
They had air and water in the suits, but little
battery - and if the heat went out, they would
freeze to death.
She quickly killed all of the lights and power
in both their suits to the minimum - except
the helmet lights, so they could make sure
the other was still alive.
The pair stayed like that for a whole day,
with absolutely nothing but the creature’s
digestion and their own breathing.
After a while, the Corporal’s face was visible
- he looked tired and scared.
She says that thirteen hours in, the kid started
talking and babbling.
She calmed him down and they both slept for
a bit, but were rudely awoken by falling into
the stomach of the creature.
They both fell out into a small chamber filled
with liquid - and barely a moment later, their
suits began to melt in the stomach acid.
She yelled and they both ran for a hole in
the wall - SCP-835’s sphincter.
At this point it was very clear that they
made it into the intestine - and it was worse
than the stomach.
I’m sure you can imagine how horrifying
it must have been to be in the mix of this
creature’s fecal waste.
Disgusted and vomiting, the Corporal and Lieutenant
picked each other up, knowing they were making
strides of the terrible ordeal.
But reached a dead stop - the creatures rectal
hole was tightly shut, blocking their escape.
They decided to wait, knowing it would have
to excrete eventually - and after an undetermined
amount of time - I mean any time spent in
some thing’s intestines waiting to be pooped
out is too much time - The Lieutenant was
shot out into the sea - but without the Corporal.
She is obviously angry, telling the agents
to do something “expunged” before declaring
she needs a drink and to sleep.
What a horrifying story - but there are gaps.
Let’s take a look at the uncensored documentation
for SCP-835.
First, let’s go back to the containment
procedures.
What SCP-835 is to be fed is explained: any
kind of local fish, but higher level mammals
if it goes into a “rage state” - including
humans.
In fact, it seems to calm down when digesting
higher mammals - maybe it’s developed a
taste for human flesh.
In any case, the feedings should never happen
without heavy supervision.
Next, the results of performing tests on the
samples of SCP-835 the Foundation was able
to get.
SCP-835 is no normal coral: it seems to be
made from what can only be described as “basic
human biological components”.
The hard outer shell is super-dense calcium,
like your bones but hundreds of times harder.
The polyps are covered with the same kind
of enamel that you’d find on your teeth,
and the fleshy muscle that the tentacles are
made of is mostly mutated tongue cells.
The creature seems to have most of the biological
systems we have, but they’ve all degraded
or mutated into almost unrecognizability - except
the digestive and reproductive systems, which
are highly advanced.
835-I5, the bacteria unique to the anomaly,
is explained: it’s how SCP-835 reproduces.
When vertebrates are infected with it, they
will undergo a variety of symptoms, gaining
huge amounts of weight despite always being
hungry for things that normally can’t be
eaten like wood and raw meat.
Their skin will harden and form polyps across
its surface.
Their biological systems will slowly stop
working, and they’ll become aggressive.
And then, they will drastically reduce in
intelligence and motion except for the desire
to enter the sea.
Sound familiar?
That’s right: being infected by it turns
the victim into another SCP-835 instance,
with no way to cure it.
And just like it seems, SCP-835 is still somewhat
aware and intelligent - at one point, this
thing was a normal human.
Just in case that’s not horrible enough,
the after-action report has also been thoroughly
declassified.
Let’s take another look to see the real,
full story of what happened to Lieutenant
C and Corporal H inside SCP-835.
The first reveal is when Corporal H was being
pulled into the polyp.
He was screaming and crying, begging for help:
“Oh God, it’s eating me, I don’t want
to die!”.
Command tells Lieutenant C to abort the mission,
but she refuses to leave one of her men behind,
holding his hand while hooking them together.
Then the line snapped and they were pulled
in.
Just as they were escaping the stomach and
right as she hit the sphincter, she realized
- the walls of the stomach were lined with
human faces, screaming and wailing and begging
to be killed.
She pulled her weapon out and began firing
into them, and she would’ve melted if Corporal
H hadn’t pushed her through.
In the intestine, the Corporal began to complain
of a rancid smell - she checked, and realized
he had a breach in his suit, but quickly patched
it.
But it was too late - she looked at his face,
and it was growing pustules already.
They burst, spraying blood, and he begged
to be put out of his misery.
But when the Lieutenant shot her gun at him,
all it produced were empty clicks.
She had wasted all the ammo on the crying
stomach faces.
Suddenly tentacles burst through the Corporals
faceplate and simultaneously pinned the Lieutenant
down.
She managed to flip what had been the Corporal
over and wrestle what was left of him back
through the sphincter into the stomach, where
his body began to melt in the acid.
But before it did, she saw the Corporal’s
face, smiling, and saying he loved her before
he died.
Then she felt a burst of energy and was shot
through the exit.
With a troubled gleem in her eye she stands
there telling her story to the agnet.
She takes a second to gain some strength and
then says “I didn’t make it out intact.
My suit was breached, and I didn’t even
realize until I took it off and saw the rash
on my skin.”
Realizing she’s going to die, she suddenly
puts the room she’s in on lockdown and orders
the debriefing agent to evacuate everyone
else aboard immediately.
Just before she kills the feed, she makes
one request: that the Foundation not try to
decontaminate the small boat.
Just to abandon ship and scuttle it on top
of SCP-835, on top of the Corporal.
That way, they can be together, in some kind
of sick resting place.
SCP-835 is the horrible tale of things that
can go wrong at the Foundation and two people
doing their best in a brutal situation.
But with the modern containment protocols
and ensuring people know what happened to
the pair, the Foundation can ensure no one
ends up like the Lieutenant and the Corporal
again.
Now go watch “SCP-3000 - Anantashesha”
and “SCP-057-IT - Under the Sea” for more
SCP Explained videos about mysterious anomalies
that can be found lurking beneath the waves.
Surf’s up!